I currently put equal parts, Epsom salts, and filtered water into a spray bottle that spray
it on my torso and legs after a sauna when my pores are open. Is this a good way to supplement
magnesium or am I missing out on another vital form? Well, Epsom salts is a magnesium salt.
Now, there has been other topical magnesium that we've used in the past. There's a magnesium oil
that you could get as a spray. I think it's an olive oil or some base.
And for that was really popular, and it's making it come back, sometimes these supplement things
have trends and it's trending more. The magnesium oil is trending more. But it isn't magnesium salt
that when it gets on your skin, do you absorb some? Yes, do you absorb some Epsom salts when you
take an Epsom salt bath? Yes, you do. Do you absorb a lot? No, not really. You know, you don't
really absorb a lot through your skin. The negative of the oils, or doing what you're doing,
dissolving the salt in a water and spray it on, it can leave a salty residue on your skin.
And you notice that, and especially with the oil, people used to notice like a white residue that
was left. That's just the magnesium salt that's left. I really don't think you're absorbing a lot.
Of course, you're not paying a lot for the Epsom salts filtered water. So I don't say negative to that.
But the magnesium oils that are now making it come back trend-wise to use as a topical
source of magnesium. For the cost of it, it just takes some magnesium. Magnesium is a fairly inexpensive
supplement to take. Why try to absorb it through your skin when you could just, it absorbs quite
well in your gut. So now I understand this is an expensive way to do it, but I think the oil is
kind of silly. People who say, well, it's better because my child won't take a pill. Well, there's
magnesium powders that are, you know, flavored with natural, you know, good, natural flavor.
That is that kids will drink. I don't see really a benefit of the oil. I don't see a benefit
of the topical. I just don't know how much a person is really absorbing. So I don't, I'm not a big fan
of that.